citizens of the reject Nation it is John it
is Roxy stryer and we are back to continue
our journey through the blade films Blade
2 today starring Wesley the Snipes how are
you feeling Roxy are you excited you know
what got me stoked what all of their comments
that were puns on blade that I asked for and
they gave me I read every single one some
of them went over your head they did one guy
was like I'm not sharp enough to come up with
a blade pun and I was like you'll get ah I
see what you did keep those puns coming people
and also keep hitting that like button that
helps us out the most as well as subscribing
hitting the notification Bell and keep subscribing
to Roxy and the world girls all across the
social medias they got great content for you
that you can be missing out on right this
moment unless you subscribe and uh Hey last
but not least if you want to get the full
experience of these reactions everything that
doesn't make these highlight reels come join
us over at patreon.com the real reject sync
up with your own copy of Blade Two join us
for all the fun check out everything else
we got over there as well and without further
ado it's time for blade too oh the rhyme bars
it makes it better when you say bar it always
does
New 52 it's a reference [Laughter] that Amalgamated
Universe crossover
are you okay to give blood we came up with
some unusual results from your blood test
how unusual as unusual as you're acting your
blood has a very rare phenotype one we haven't
encountered before
here's a lot the good news bad news scenario
Jared good news for us
bad news whoa for you is he a day Walker blood
welcome to Prime Time [__]
whoa dang
oh
fish oh
[Music]
what just came out of his mouth forget what
you think vampires exist
my name is blade they call me the day woke
up that's right 20 years ago I met a man that
changed that Whistler oh buddy rip two years
ago he was attacked they took him and turned
him into the thing I hate most oh they turned
him we didn't know that right they left it
off like he killed himself
hahaha it's like Wolverine's lashes yeah or
like two steaks two fangs
nice
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter] [Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music] what year is this two thousand two
two that was interesting that visual was interesting
looked a little different than the first one
yeah it'll be interesting to see how the effects
grow and the ways in which they shoot around
the effects
love that Boomerang knife
good stunt
forever
take me to it and I'll consider you a loose
ends whoa [Music]
bloody cocaine I think it is that's awesome
actually logistically I don't know if that
would work because I'm looking on Powder together
would not be able to maintain that consistency
maybe it's like Crystal
[Music] [Laughter]
oh Night at the Roxbury that's right
nice
[Music] damn you want to get nuts let's get
nuts
oh
you can tell he feels really confident in
this role absolutely it's like I crushed you
last time I'm settled then tell me to slow
down my martial arts skills old man look at
what they've done to you whoa whoa awakened
from The Matrix I want to know the science
behind why they keep them in that water it
must be some kind of blood suspension yo yes
of course a classic blood suspension well
let's assume everything has blood in it
let's go poor thing let's go home buddy your
daughters boys and girls whoa what is that
Norman Reedus oh no way if there's anything
left of you in there listen up in the morning
those blinds are going to open whether you're
cured or not damn is he using like Karen's
formula did she perfect it yeah I just thought
that this far in you weren't able to
he looks like Eddie Furlong a little bit what
do you know Norman Reed is from mainly The
Walking Dead I haven't seen Boondock Saints
are you sitting next to me I know blasphemy
one day how'd you find me started out in Moscow
in Romania they kept moving you around how
long was I gone too long years okay but Exposition
us for a second how long was he
where's Mark whoa
what are you doing in the man's engine let's
go cannabis Josh you can call me Scott though
gave it a more aggressive exhaust profile
ramping burn the damn thing out before your
next oil change the what's your problem Poppy
I built this operation you asked wife
yeah Daryl
whoa body temperature 50 I guess suck head
damn the alarm sets off the cinematography
coverage too okay ninjas cool very cool they
are ninjas
cool outfit yeah Yep this feels like it should
be a Cirque de Soleil show oh my God Cirque
du so blade let's do it
all the Twirls
no I like they're using the boomerang blade
more though that's the one thing I wanted
more of the first one yeah what do you think
these people are I guess they gotta be like
super Vamp ninjas or something whoa
whoa yeah
well you could have just said so we represent
the ruling body of the Vampire Nation they
want to meet with you
[Music] my name is Assad this is Nisa
two more beautiful people yep but now there's
something else loose on the streets something
worse than you now we gotta work together
sometimes the ADR is a little off yeah and
that's fine it's a mark of the time yeah it
is totally fine oh oh I really don't like
the way he looks this is Overlord Eli damasquinos
big an arbor virus carried in the saliva of
predators in 72 hours its spreads through
the human bloodstream creating new parasitic
organs like cancer they did a great job with
his design yeah creepy magic of silicone on
olive oil sure glycerin Jared nomak Pizza
not just humans but vampires as well you want
me to hunt them what do you think they'll
turn on next we spent two years training a
small Tactical Unit the blood pack we want
you to lead them the blood pack I had enough
of their world if you [__] and breaks
because they're no longer top of the food
chain I think you should watch them nobody
goes cold turkey from The Thirst in just one
night okay all right I was thinking that was
a little quick yo Norman Reedus is Bomb yeah
man I'm glad he's on the squad looking to
get hooked up maybe what do you have a horse
Hawaiian ice whatever you need Hawaiian ice
horse like a snow cone I like that what if
I need you [Music]
whoa wait what's that what's that whoa wait
what was that I am not sure oh it's a piece
of the glass from the oh yeah
it looked like a crystal
oh
this movie is a vibe to it it's like is the
vibe yeah it's dark yeah in a good way squirmy
light hammer verlane priest Snowman what Donnie
Yen do you think that's why we weren't allowed
to look anything up all right and run Perlman
no please whoa if I'm not recognizing the
rest of them I feel bad but damn I'm stoked
right now you've been training for two years
to take me out and now here I am oh so exciting
Here I Am Ready in front of you go ahead Adolf
here gets the first shot
oh
wow now you got an explosive device stuck
to the back of your hand Suicide Squad we're
talking all the night places where vampires
congregate blood banks safe houses bigger
the better what's first
freaking cool so cool the House of Pain Jump
Around Jump Around jump up jump up but get
down it's good it's good I sat down with Ron
Perlman for an hour really he was amazing
oh I'm jealous could not have been cooler
I listened to that house of pain song for
an hour it's almost as though almost as dope
you won't ask for one of us like I give a
[__] no he's right why don't you post
up on the roof over there cover our backs
so the blood packs calling the shots now huh
and I want to lose you again Whistler yeah
vibes Vibes oh they do look dope wow Donny
what yeah man I am excited we're on a Donny
tear you gotta be kidding me
another Blood Rave
they all look like Eliza Dushku that was a
look back yeah a specific whoa hey
guy from earlier he'll enjoyed that whoa what's
happening there they're doing like Body Mods
and like Kink club stuff but like to the vampire
degree look at them after these bastards they're
not even pure Bloods why don't we just kill
everyone what is his name he feels like another
Sons of Anarchy dude [Music] [Laughter]
oh Great's in the floor so the blood will
drip through could be for the booze day Walker
he could smell the daywalker yeah he's got
to have a signature scent is anyone born half
human a day Walker I don't get that scent
we'll have to dive back into the comments
because people were kind of enlightening us
yeah I think what's the man on the roof I
got on the roof of my bus oh no is it Whistler
is Whistler not doing so good a pretty cool
sticky camera you should get some yeah
yeah oh um
his back really freaks me out his back they're
like yeah tiny little rows of teeth look I
have Goosebumps everywhere right now you really
do yeah it really freaked I don't know for
some reason the style is really grosses me
out yeah I mean it is it's effective yeah
this is a dumb question do guns work in the
rain I think it can present issues but in
movies they always work in the rain
oh no no what am I to you is the enemy of
my enemy my friend or my friend
laughs
let's go let's go Donnie they remind me of
these villains in Buffy whoa
more Donnie more fights more Donnie more fights
more Donny more fights
come on yes
[Music]
okay
oh my God there's so much going on it's hard
to tell where we're who's winning
come on [Music]
I love guy liner yeah right even just pointing
Donny's so freaking cool yes
guess you won't be needing any of those bits
that was Hardcore did they split his dick
in half and it's I think how you feeling theoretically
yes are you okay I'm having Phantom pains
but it's okay don't even worry about don't
even trip I hurt
[Applause]
whoa oh my God there's like Little Shop of
Horrors that was some feed me see more [__]
I've never seen that on a map before
[Applause]
yeah oh and if they scratch you does it all
right oh God they're like aliens
oh what is happening [Music]
yes
I think the scratches are gonna do it still
not he did bite them he's flying yeah look
closer at his neck there you're right behind
him listen to me if you're under attack use
your UV lights use your UV lights I can't
take the light
Where Have You Been everyone's fighting a
battle you might not understand John that's
true I should not judge [Applause]
oh that's so gross really well done yeah it's
a badass effect
we have the same enemy we want the same thing
oh no this is wild a big chunk of this movie
has been this like one long extended sequence
you know yeah it's like a big fight imagine
how long this would take yeah
oh here we go
reload
ah
damn it
please like what oh what kidding me
oh blade doesn't sweat a whole lot but I do
like those moments where he's like what damn
it yeah it's like the little micro movements
yeah the same thing blade
he is right it is kind of interesting premise
because they do want the same things not fully
but partially yeah it's like similar motivations
but one of you is going to take over the world
oh nice
God what a boss so the vampires want the people
that can eat the vampires suck the vampires
gone yeah and this people who can suck the
vampires want the vampires gone they bought
each other's gone blade wants both parties
gone yeah he sided with one of them as opposed
to the other seems like well because if the
the super Vamps are gonna like take over like
there'll just be no one left if they succeed
because they'll eat the humans though vampires
they'll eat everybody the vampires are trying
to take over the humans too though it seems
like in this world he's already starting to
change yeah god of much so far Krishna checker
man they keep telling you about the bullets
you gotta get him some sunlight come on man
just put him out of his [__] misery finish
him that way yeah where's get your UV move
yes
foreign
he just disappeared where were you we lost
a man priest I'm gonna carve his [__]
name on your chest priest would be an interesting
name to Carl when you're dressed true it would
be a great conversation starter and it comes
with some implications sure followed it down
found it just like this I think they came
through here he was trying to crawl back in
the cupboard and caught his arm uh you've
already lost one of your own how many more
are you willing to sacrifice seemingly overall
even your own daughter everyone there we go
even her
yes he is such a Star Wars villain yeah or
a hard Conan what's killing him they need
fresh blood every couple of hours or they
start feeding on themselves oh almost feel
bad for him open the mouth
come on
this is [__] I think so great insult blade
is the best guy I can't believe it's him it's
Ron Perlman it's Donnie and like what only
the tongue carries the virus it is injected
through these barbs wow
it's a more Powerpuff Girls I'm telling you
did Bert McCracken have some or Craig McCracken
whatever his name is have something to do
with this oh dude these things are as different
from us guys pay attention
hardwired right
oh brains dead body's still trying to feed
yeah what happened to Sunrise we aren't huh
if I can suss out the light source maybe I
can make some sort of UV flash bang grenade
or something big cried already yeah but you
didn't have disgusted working on it then now
did you
decided to take them back to my tent for a
little Threes Company action blade shows up
saves my ass and the Powerpuff Girls was playing
the whole time quite a lesson on threesomes
beware it's a trap don't ever trust it
maybe you were right
all right hey Brand New Bag I like them Bobby
too I like the merging good character growth
for these two what is this [__] pheromones
harvested from the Reaper's adrenal glands
they're gonna key to it they gonna love you
be real careful when you pop your love all
right UVS have a 10 second delay just remember
to take cover oh you do care about her yeah
maybe it's the love story I was hoping for
yeah maybe we'll get some blade romance I
don't think so
trying to attract them not scare them all
yeah well some of us can't see in the dark
nipple head what am I supposed to do just
get some of those yellows on sunglasses oh
there you go sure nipple head yeah I've never
heard that before I'm gonna start using that
I don't even know what if somebody threw that
insult at me and be like oh what do I do now
how do I come back at that yes
come on I just want a 10 minute Donnie and
fight scene that's all I want to do we haven't
utilized him enough
oh no and he's with this guy damn it ain't
nobody here but you and US buttercup uh no
no
no no fair
drop some sunlight on him he's not your light
Hammer anymore
but life
both she didn't want to live without him it's
kind of beautiful desperate move
Lisa
oh God all the bones so sinister sinister
six right now Venom's gonna bust through any
time
six five wow
[Music]
interesting image
come on man try to stink me to death old man
Frick y'all gotta learn [__] like that
never ends well where's the ball pack I don't
leave it down that count give me the rest
of the fan holes
oh yeah time to nut up or shut up you obviously
do not know
that's better I thought I got it and he did
better it's okay we can't all be as cool as
blade Roxy that's what I get [Music] laughs
come on and I haven't mentioned the bomb lever
is stuck ah you jerk but it looks like the
bomb was there right well yeah you said I
never stuck so I don't know what he did to
it
yes damn
foreign
oh my God wow
wait oh you will survive this only to tell
blade about this ring what yeah
you heard mosquitoes right mosquitoes yes
I'm glad I'm not crazy in my other vampire
shows that ring it makes you a day Walker
oh but I don't think that's what's Happening
Here you never know seems like a blood thing
yeah maybe the gene that creates these Uber
Vamps comes from a mosquito like an ancient
blood strain preserved over centuries in Millennia
or they're using mosquitoes to spread it Army
of mosquitoes no
oh there is no lover of Love shipper ships
happy ending in this nah you could save her
dude he looks sad like a he's giving her his
blood I love too that he like he can bring
the pathos from behind those sunglasses oh
there's something sweet about this moment
it's kind of like the yeah it's like a tender
version in Reverse from the first movie when
she lets him feed on her to save his life
[Music]
oh damn you guys you've done a great job not
that great
charred up his faces busted bro yesterday
she Dishonored family crest by feeding off
of him or just by not succeeding in the mission
they took him all our weapons even your sword
somebody's been keeping tabs on us from inside
especially your sword bro the reaper strain
didn't evolve it was designed from the mosquitoes
for years I've struggled with all kind of
any hereditary weaknesses whoa embryos nomec
was the first a failure that'd be a new pure
race begotten from my own flesh did she not
know immune to Silver
and even sunlight what about garlic you want
to explain how nomeg got a hold of this ring
family
from father to son oh boy you got a choice
to make Nissan is it Nisa or Lisa Nisa the
man oh
kiss your ass goodbye [Music] oh you're wasting
your time man bomb's a dud it's never supposed
to explode you're supposed to make you feel
in control oh no
damn you see this ugh they needed my help
to bring him here to control nomac the old
[__] he was always just fake I mean look
at him and I was psyched when you were bonding
sad about this what do you think about that
man two things I've been on to you since they
turned you two it's not a dud oh great whoa
[Laughter] damn feels like a waste of the
one bomb you had though hey but it was a good
moment yeah if you had to blow up one person
it's always good to remind us who's the smartest
in the room and it's blade we're going to
harvest your blood then bone marrow organs
everything will find the missing key to creating
day walkers fun
wow keep talking Honky Tonk just makes my
son to me the next world
stab him with the cuffs our enemies saved
my life twice and you have used us your own
children oh no who do you think God really
favors in the web so you believe in God the
spider is a fly in that moment I'm sure he
means the spider yeah but no man he doesn't
know this location
[Laughter]
yeah let's go Whistler go whistling go whistling
go go oh we're supposed to believe he really
beat him up that bad that he could get away
okay yeah just two punches he's good boom
boom done
sustained
he's probably so confused like where's that
coming from
I object to being shot like this
yeah you gotta cut that wrist feed him [Music]
oh boy
God that is really good grossest coolest effect
[Music]
thank you is that like Stellan Skarsgard or
something feel like someone familiar is under
this makeup here felt like it was like refined
or something that would be wild it's not but
yeah
go on kid go come on he needs blood [Music]
he's gonna emerge from that like super hulky
yeah what are you an idiot Ron yeah Ron oh
[Laughter] you haven't had a tasted the real
thing in a while too
the sound yes
That Base [Applause] [Music] pimple head ain't
got nothing on you
thank you
ah sounded almost like a Wilhelm scream
so cool it's like a screaming style but with
a taser prod
like my daddy said right before he killed
my mom want anything done right you got to
do it yourself what a weird sure thing for
us to learn [Music] whoa can you blush
[Music]
[Laughter]
nice great Kell yeah destroy those embryos
too wow [Music] we're locked in can I suppose
yes isn't it sad that you die not by the hand
of your enemy but by that of your own children
after I tried to have you killed
the
kill him right now yeah if it's coming
oh yeah
whoa
milk wow
Peter died in a tragic Sun bite accident
whoa Turn to Stone like his heart
[Applause] oh it's a great teeth shot just
then of her opening up that mouth blade it
could end right here damn
this is gonna be a good one oh yeah what's
the fate of Nisa right now she's on the track
to turning
whoa
[Laughter] see the way those doors bent
all right [Music]
the people's elbow there's like a wrestling-esque
quality to some of this yeah the drama the
moves and the wind-ups and the big moves
I could use a good back crack yeah same back's
been jacked up all week oh yeah
[Music] ow
God the way they're shooting these effects
yeah really great
oh through the side oh get him in the heart
yeah yeah yeah even though there's bone around
it he passed it
wow interesting oh I kind of feel for him
a bit of a tragic figure
whoa
well done what about Nisa and she can't be
long for this world she got bit but we know
he has that cure for regular I want to die
while I'm still a vampire
oh you were the one who didn't suck yeah I
want to see the sun your parents aren't your
fault yeah right I'd want to see this on too
I think that's how I'd want to go yeah first
and last sunrise
[Music]
kiss kiss one more time kiss kiss [Music]
buddy oh [Music] motherboard number three
enjoyment
hey this guy you sure that the girls are a
life last time I checked as opposed to dead
yep
tissues of course you know
I think I forgot about you did you [Music]
yes perfect yes yes
David has Square well done oh dude legit
it's a nice little button on the end too
Wesley Snipes a producer on Toby and Mark
dude he got a producer and an exec producer
credit well done [Music] what'd you think
it was so different than the first one really
good yeah this was much more of a straight
up action movie sure like it was like jam-packed
top to bottom we are going to show you every
type of fight every bit of action um like
you won't be able to breathe the whole time
yes I feel like if that's what they were trying
to accomplish mission accomplished yeah like
I thought they they really nicely built off
the tone of the first movie because it still
has some of that mood but it it definitely
is like faster Pace much more chop chop you
have a lot more characters at least like you
know you have a sort of Ensemble that blade
is like saddled with for part of it yeah this
Alpha maleness of Wesley Snipes and Ron Perlman
yeah just like there was just so much testosterone
in this film yeah Norman Reedus and just like
the whole thing that hurt man I liked see
that's the thing is like they lured me in
really good with him and obviously I think
nowadays you know that the effect of that
only works so much better because we have
an even greater association with who Norman
Reedus is and we trust him inclined to like
him yeah so yeah it just it pulls one over
on you that much more effectively from this
vantage point I mean I'm sure it still worked
you know back when this first dropped but
uh but yeah I thought he was a great addition
and like they even took time to be like oh
man him and Whistler like they're they're
growing to like each other how cool uh and
then yeah the the double cross comes around
like yeah I thought they had like a really
interesting evolution of the vampire's interesting
story you know they gave you a good amount
of things that you know it's like we got certain
motifs from the first movie back or certain
characters like Whistler comes back um but
yeah just the way they built on I thought
was great the only thing it could have used
more of was Donnie Yen 100 that I was so sad
that he got murked the way he did and making
out you know how I feel I you know honestly
like if they're if I you know can he find
love I feel like you know Blade Trinity uh
from the vague things I've heard over time
is maybe not the best blade but he's played
Trinity the third one I think so yeah and
uh I don't know though there still could be
one more opportunity therein for some passion
you know some passionate Romance yeah I don't
think anybody else but me is wanting that
but I really do just want blade to be happy
this was a pretty simple movie that sounds
like a bad thing and it's not just the story
was pretty straightforward there was just
a couple of twists and turns like okay um
she her being his daughter and him being his
son and also Norman Reedus switching sides
and other than that it was like the theme
the enemy of the enemy is either your friend
or your enemy and in this everyone's your
effing enemy yeah yeah seriously don't trust
them that's why I was harping on this at the
beginning when it's just like he why he would
side with the vampires when he's a vampire
hunter and the vampires still want to eat
all the humans but the vampire eating people
just want to eat all the vampires and all
the humans it just was like not I knew there
was going to be some kind of a reveal or twist
because that's not the Math's not mathing
you know like didn't none of them want the
same thing as you the enemy of your enemy
can only be your friend if you really want
the same thing and they didn't yeah I mean
I I bought it in so far as it's like okay
here's this greater threat that we need you
to take care of but it's probably a bigger
threat than you are oh Mike mignola a visual
consulted on this um who's that uh I I think
that's a that's like a comic book author a
comic book artist it's a name I I've I've
seen on involved with Hellboy too maybe I
don't know Comics I I feel like yeah it's
probably that makes sense um it's so good
but yeah I don't know I I mean I bought it
in terms of it being bought it too tenuous
like okay I'll help you because technically
this does behoove the both of us but the second
the job's done I'm gonna I'm back to hunting
you guys totally yeah that's how I took that
I definitely bought it I'm just glad that
wasn't what it was because I was sitting here
thinking like while I do buy this and it makes
sense I don't think this would end well and
it didn't so yeah it's like you know the prospect
of like oh and maybe blade and the vampires
will come to some sort of truce or something
like that's never going to happen right totally
yeah but do you how do you feel I know it's
right after about the first versus the second
is one more up your alley that's a really
good question honestly like this one was so
Punchy and I really loved the design work
and again the way it built off the first movie
I don't know I I mean there was certainly
stuff about this that I think was like really
tight and uh like citro or tight like they
kept it tight both both yeah yeah I mean like
there was a lot of really cool evolution of
again the effects and just the visual world
that this is like I thought this nicely adapted
some of the kinetic visual elements of the
previous movie and obviously the really distinctive
lighting all these like Reds and blues and
things like that um I would honestly right
now I kind of have a hard time picking which
one I I like more because they're both different
in ways I appreciate and uh uh yeah I don't
know maybe by the end of this review I'll
have a better ride I mean there's one more
your favorite as of now this one to me was
a lot grosser like this was more what I feel
like and I I wouldn't call this a straight
up horror movie but to me it kind of was because
the whole time I was like I have the ickiest
feeling inside this is making me like really
having sorry there was a gorilla song I have
to anyway continue so I was what I was saying
was really of interest you if you were talking
about gorilla no of course it is wait what's
gorillas there was it was in the music credits
gorilla love gorillas a lot of different kinds
of music it was gorillas on my mind featuring
red man I'm really happy for you thank you
I appreciate you being here for this momentum
for sure it's not like a big deal the grossness
of the effects and whatnot so I it feels like
they just are two completely different genres
almost to me like the first one I feel like
really was um and I don't want to say used
a lot more calm no Reapers no real Reapers
were hurt during the making of This film it's
funny it's funny continue
oh gorilla I'm sorry it's it's give me this
year look at all the credits it's good I I
loved I I you know I grew up in a credits
household yeah I feel you I I totally feel
you um I think that the first one had a lot
more comic book movie tropes to it which is
not a fair even thing to say even though I
don't mean it as negative I do mean as positive
but it created those tropes you know like
this was the OG of a lot of those things yeah
especially on on screen yeah right so I think
it was more like classic comic book movie
and the second one was more like Gore and
guts and like um doing its own thing and felt
very confident and had its own Freedom so
I feel like first one maybe better date night
fun movie second one more like uh you're having
a a night with the homies and you're like
ah gross man yeah let's watch something hard
yeah yeah in a way this not it's not a good
one-to-one but I think there is a some comparison
you could make between the difference between
like alien and aliens kind of happens here
with Blade versus Blade 2 at least in like
they're both pretty like action-packed and
they're both pretty Snappy but like the first
movie certainly takes more time for certain
things and it has a little bit more like breathing
room which I wasn't like missing yeah or anything
like that but it just yeah it feels like it
was paced and sort of disposed a bit differently
and this one yeah had like really kind of
upped that kinetic energy and yeah like everything
was like Chop Chop not in a way that felt
like yeah it was pared down from something
or slided but yeah like much more to the point
much more action-packed and more yeah the
first one maybe reminds me more distinctly
of like a graphic novel whereas this is more
down the rabbit hole like even more horror
Vibes and horror movies [__] and and certainly
at home obviously within the Comic Book Realm
um but it's yeah and this one I wasn't even
really thinking about that aspect yeah I'm
with you the the effects of the the super
vampires but the next stuff oh yeah unreal
yeah and and I gotta say like I love the design
of that and I love that they took the time
to you know somebody Guillermo del Toro or
or maybe it was in the comics or whoever like
they took the time with these Reapers to figure
out a biology for that like I love that they
had that whole autopsy sequence because it's
like okay these things are completely different
inside and like this whole like bone covered
heart thing and yeah opening up the jowls
and seeing this like disgusting Barbed tongue
apparatus and I mean part of that especially
that one profile shot I'm sure is an alien
tribute but but yeah I just love the the amount
of detail and attention and care that went
into designing these disgusting creatures
and then just the effects looked great on
them and and across this movie I thought they
did a really nice job I mean like in the earliest
scenes you can tell that like the people getting
powered up you know like those look a bit
like Graphics now and yeah you can tell when
CG is happening but I thought like they it
was a combination of they knew when to put
like the most work into you know those hero
shots where you need it to look great because
the lighting is very bright and whatnot um
but I thought yeah they shot stuff well to
really bolster both the reaper effects as
well as the comic book movie requisite like
flipping and acrobatic effects and I thought
they did a nice job here of blending stunts
and shooting the stunts in such a way that
the transition between like the CG body double
for some crazy Flip or whatever or you know
crashing into a wall like those transitions
looked really smooth like this is one of those
movies that to me exemplifies it's like yeah
okay so this was 2002 which you know you're
getting better and better as time goes on
you know in Leaps and Bounds with CG but this
felt like one of those things that that looks
better to me than the time it was made in
suggests it would because they knew how to
shoot this stuff yeah I'm very with you too
about the like I guess it would be the allocation
of their funds the things that I really hoped
would look good looked sick the the dissolving
effect um or like the sunlight effect of the
blue and kind of goes away that was interesting
an interesting choice and I feel like maybe
that was just it still looked good enough
but I think maybe that saved them a little
money so that they could do the throat Reaper
situation which clearly cost them a ton because
each one of those was like so intense looking
and great um and like you at the beginning
I was like okay some of these effects and
then when we get into it I'm like wow they
really used their money on this thing yeah
exactly the choreography in this is like the
fight choreography in this you just can't
even I cannot imagine how long that took that's
crazy the the other thing I was thinking what
is it called I have a couple friends who do
this and I always forget the name of it those
people who go into the rooms and make the
sounds oh fully fully art oh my God the fully
artists for this man every song all the swishes
and clangs and gooey sounds and yeah all the
way now it's like a feel like it's one of
those movies that is like a feast for the
eyes and ears in so many ways and two years
without the headphones too I was like yeah
oh yeah yeah and you're in all these dank
and drippy and icky locations and stuff like
that that drippy bro drippy don't moist locals
bro come at me with drippy moist drippy moisture
this movie was drippy moist you are dripping
it's drippy moist okay let's hear the building
a blade two wrap then dripping oh no I'm not
a good freestyle rap right I would need to
sit down with the pen and Pad you know classic
style okay I'ma hold you to it I'm not afraid
to rap about blade we're back for the sequel
so we're keeping it real all right we got
Reapers to hunt Boomerang knife gun and some
sunlight um running out of Rhymes and I'm
just thinking of motifs now I see you you
said hunt the only thing I know yeah I was
going I was like don't say the word that will
get this video demonetized there's not much
room yeah bunt bunt there you go I'm gonna
punt the ball to you it just holds up his
sword someone runs through it nice little
butt you know what what Norman Reed is smoking
that they call him it has right they call
me the day Walker fast talker Street stalker
of the night give you a fright before I slice
and dice slice and dice my what you know hold
your your head off various limbs I don't know
anything that kills Vamps right honestly that
was way better than I thought I set you up
for failure and you succeeded You Found Love
in a hopeless place just now that's right
man pump the brakes I brought my steaks don't
worry oh [__] I
really liked going back to the movie for a
second garlic I'll think about it I really
liked that when Ron perlman's character had
the bomb on his head and it doesn't go off
and I'm like ah how did blade not know any
and then Blade's so smart and he's like nah
I didn't know and I was like that's our hero
yeah he knows all lured you into the Trap
so I could get back at this [__] this
rat in my organization yeah and I mean that's
like a movie Magic Moment where you're like
okay I guess he was just messing with him
but it was such a satisfying it was a bummer
again these do feel like they're from a slightly
earlier time in the way that they're crafted
and thought out because like I don't know
I just feel like if this I I keep being curious
to know what the new Blade's gonna turn out
looking and feeling like just because these
movies do feel I don't I don't want to say
like real movies as if to imply that the current
movies don't feel real but there's something
there's something different about some watching
something like this it's like you have the
dedication of Wesley Snipes and and people
in the comments were like yeah they had to
tell them to slow down because he's like a
legit ass martial artist and he's credited
too for some of the choreography and stuff
so yeah and so you have like the tangibility
of both his performance as an actor and his
physicality as you know Blade the freaking
Warrior um but then yeah you have I don't
know just like the way the story goes and
the attention to the details feels just I
don't know it breathes uh more like a natural
script does to me through these two movies
thus far than I don't know I don't feel as
much maneuvering from behind the camera or
as much like expository sort of like hand
holding in these movies and uh I like that
like it I don't know there's just something
about these that feels quintessentially of
an earlier point in time obviously they are
it's a little simple which is good like I
think that's kind of what you're trying it's
not overloaded with like and then and then
and now you know it's kind of like okay I
get this story I like these character I understand
what we're doing I'm enjoying watching this
yeah maybe that's not what you're saying no
no it's yeah no it's like it's it is convoluted
obviously and it is heightened but it's not
like this massive thing the stakes the situation
feel big enough without feeling like so big
that you kind of lose connection with them
mistakes the stakes it's good we'll get a
garlic thing in there well you know I was
thinking about the garlic thing you could
we could just use like licks or pick or like
you know punch them in the sure like he's
a little prick or we could go with uh like
a bulb of garlics come in bulbs don't they
oh we could we yeah I was just rhyming with
the lick part of garlic sure but you were
making a whole different word it's part of
the um I got a corgi on your cup there yeah
I do it's my dog oh you got custom-made coffee
disposable cups yeah it's not my dog I don't
have one you know what I do nice trick for
you guys I go and I buy the teas that I like
from from Coffee Bean and then I buy my own
cups and I make them myself I just saved more
power to you do it I think that's that's a
good hack they're literally giving you their
recipe you can get the flavor on your own
thank you so much um anyway but yeah like
that far pick far less hey not bad thank you
that combination yeah of like the story is
straightforward enough the action mounts in
a pretty linear way and yeah you have the
situation that feels big but not too big and
you have a good amount of physical effects
physical fight elements physical blood gags
physical just various stunts and sets and
there's like so much in camera but there's
also a lot of effects and I feel like nowadays
you fall into these traps of like the way
things are written feels a little can often
especially on this movie's type of scale can
feel sort of economically written in a different
way and can also feel uh you know especially
now with the way movies are reshot and and
geared towards the knowledge that we're gonna
rework stuff later there's just like a more
synthetic feeling in a lot of these things
now that you hope each movie will transcend
and these two blade experiences have felt
encumbered by none of that yeah I I completely
agree I really dug this if I'm gonna be a
little nitpicky it did feel a little long
to me okay when uh whereas the first one didn't
feel that way as much I think it's because
of the the some of the fight sequences they're
not monotonous monotonous
it's not like the same thing over and over
again but at some point there's so much I
action I like action movies it's not my number
one genre so it was like sometimes we'd get
out of a fight sequence go into the next fight
sequence to go into a third fight sequence
to go into the fourth fight sequence to go
into the fifth fight sequence and I at some
point I was thinking to myself like I could
use dialogue right now or a slightly more
distinct flavor that distinctifies like a
Donnie different sure I mean no the thing
is we see him we get a sequence with him using
the sword which was cool I was thrilled by
I would have loved more of and and how do
you know what he can do yeah and having a
guy like Donnie Yen like it's funny the Norman
Reedus appearance I think has gotten more
effective with age Wars I feel like the Donnie
Yen appearance kind of gets you know nowadays
with you know the profile that he has now
and what we have seen through stuff like Ip
Man and John Wick and all sorts of other things
uh yeah you feel like damn if we had gotten
some like full ass martial arts or or you
know like real sword player just something
that plays to his direct strengths and and
certainly like you know uh Wesley Snipes also
a martial artist and they do utilize that
stuff but there is a you have a lot of group
fights you have a lot of like you know uh
club or sewer fights yeah a lot of the locations
felt similar and there are because the vampire
thing you know yeah like and they're places
that we've kind of trodden in the first movie
right yeah which again this will still totally
work but just thinking of things that could
have elevated it a little bit more for me
yeah yeah there's that definitely I I wouldn't
disagree I mean like I I thought they again
brought a lot of fun and punch and spirit
to the action but like in terms of how it
was all conceived and the fact that you do
have these different you know Ensemble characters
with you know the one guy's got a big old
hammer and the one guy's got a sword and you
know like they all seem to have like their
own different little specialty you know I
think you could have maybe rung a bit more
out of that yeah yeah I I feel you or you
feel me we feel each other that's right drippy
moist they're pretty moist I'm always here
for you okay I'm just gonna cover my myself
in a layer of Glycerine next time and just
[Music]
days gone bye and I mean you know it's funny
because uh I don't think there was any Gavin
or Rossdale on this soundtrack but we are
at an interesting time in the sonics of these
movies too because we're in that very electronic
industrial hip-hop space uh and uh I appreciate
I don't know like we were grooving like there
was a lot of moments where it's like whatever's
happening right now this is me yeah yeah and
it's interesting to to kind of process these
movies because it's like going back I don't
know why the music made me think of this because
you know like the music in these movies have
changed needle drops of change I feel like
in a movie like this from this point in time
you would have needle drops but that aren't
treated as such whereas now they are much
more like they're the score elements and then
we got a needle draw you know um and so I
feel like that sensibility has changed some
and it's interesting too because I've been
sitting here going back to the The Love Story
thing in modern movies in modern any of this
superhero horror super comic book anything
I've been sitting here thinking and Chloe
and I have talked about this too on certain
videos of like I wish there not like you know
the requisite like uh we need a love interest
blah like I wish these recent movies would
bring back some kind of sense of passion or
a love story that you could get invested in
because I think those things are missing they're
largely kind of passionless in a lot of ways
or if there is a love story it's very kind
of innocuous whereas here I appreciate these
for not feeling the need to do that because
I feel like at the point in time these were
made that was a more likely thing to have
had happen so I really liked it like you have
the Karen character in the first movie who
doesn't get forced into being the love interest
even though she easily could be and they just
let her be a character who just is stuck in
this situation might be turning who knows
and has to grow and learn and at least hold
her own amidst all this chaos awesome and
then in this movie you have the Nisa character
who is I really thought they were saying Lisa
for so long well and and the way the the the
the main vampire guy yeah I would say it I
was like he had a very soft kind of way of
pronouncing things um but yeah it's like I
liked here that you had this like hint at
some kind of a connection of sorts with them
like there's the idea that they they could
but it's never like a a like a huge aspect
of the story and I thought it was just enough
here it's like if they had really wanted to
tease a romance I could have gotten on board
somehow but I like the way they left it as
just like they have some kind of connection
in that they've been on this journey together
she is easily the most benevolent of all the
vampires he's had to work with she's like
the least treacherous and and conniving and
you know she's the most sympathetic and so
I like that they at least had a tender moment
because that suggested just that like oh man
had things gone differently uh you know uh
help me suggest to me he's a mouse that if
things had gone differently uh you know I
don't know maybe there could have been something
you know more for the two of them um yeah
possibly I do think that I I get what you're
saying also because in 2002 if you were a
love interest that's kind of all you were
yeah so it I do think we've gotten better
at you can be a love interest and also a human
being um and that's why modern day movies
maybe like we see it so much more sure um
but I I cannot help myself this is a Tony
Curran is his name the priest guy well you
look at what LLC has done I can't help this
is just me and people get annoyed by this
and I totally get it I love love I love love
I love love in every like I will shoehorn
love into anything sure just because I think
it is what makes the world go around and like
as corny and cheesy as it can be it's grounding
for everybody oh when Ray Donovan he was in
seven episodes that's definitely what I'm
recognizing him from and he played uh Van
Gogh in a terrific episode of Doctor Who that's
right that's where I know him that's right
he's been in tons of stuff though Daredevil
um interesting Sons of Anarchy there you go
I was right yeah great his is worked on tons
of stuff uh yeah so I I think that it's like
most people aren't missing that love story
I just never ever has there been a love story
in a movie and I've been like I wish there
was no love story in this movie I'm like bringing
on the love show me the love I mean that's
fair yeah I I I I want I I'm with you when
it's you know when the movement itself is
actually invested in doing this and and okay
the guy who was the the the like vampire King
has been in a bunch of stuff too he was in
the King Kong uh Peter Jackson movies and
wanted he's in the dial of Destiny yeah I
feel like he plays a lot of like german-esque
characters I do too I've heard a lot of demons
different things uh you know that's a whole
other conversation to have but uh but yeah
I I'm with you I I wish there was more love
that these movies cared about and that could
you know touch your heart because that's fine
but it's just my little It's My Thing sure
sure that was my thing you can't have my thing
it's my thing I'm the only one who can like
love I will I will uh give up this fight then
oh okay drippy moist that's right drippy moist
signing off but yeah man really good Ensemble
I thought even even the people like from the
faces I was familiar with to the faces I wasn't
as familiar with I liked everybody's presence
for the most part there are a few things yeah
like you know them being like Oh we got you
alone Whistler we're gonna you know you do
we lost one of ours now we're gonna take one
of his you know it's like That's a classic
sort of Hench move or whatever there are tropes
in the movie but I thought for the most part
it it kept just a nice clip and uh and yeah
it was pretty conscientious about everything
it tried to do like my dad said to my mom
right before he killed her yes what if you
want to get the job done right do it yourself
or whatever
good job with Blade Two honestly this could
have gone horribly wrong and it was really
good so that's huge Ops to Wesley Snipe too
because he's just so Wesley Snipes is like
so um like you can't look at anybody else
when he's on screen he's just just he's a
star yeah he's just so good and I feel like
that's that's what we were talking about last
time I just can't picture somebody else playing
blade but no we're gonna see it and I mean
the combination two of him and and Kris Kristoff
uh Christopherson is it's a hard tongue twister
yeah
it's starting to not sound real I know like
uh I don't know any any word will do uh but
yeah whoever chose to pair them up as as blade
and Whistler the casting excellent choice
and uh yeah and I like to uh it's always fun
seeing like a something from a director's
uh you know repertoire that isn't quite at
the point where like you know this was made
at a time where I wasn't like aware of Guillermo
del Toro and so now going back it's like cool
it doesn't have like 100 of all of his stylistic
earmarks that we now associate with him but
it definitely is like an interesting beat
along his journey and certainly speaks to
his love of comics and horror and fantasy
and and yeah it's it's cool because it doesn't
scream Del Toro but I can definitely see how
there's yeah the growth of his voice through
something like this for sure for sure I mean
it's also really hard to scream Del Toro when
you're working with like a comic book movie
that's a studio that I'm sure there's a lot
of input from a lot of people yeah absolutely
on this but a different time too like this
is this is a sequence of movies I would be
thrilled to go back and listen to commentaries
or hear about because yeah it's like looking
at the array of comic book movies now it seems
like Batman 89 certainly gets a lot of credit
for you know helping open the door to like
oh we can take this kind of seriously and
something like this I mean certainly feels
like it's unencumbered by anybody going Comics
or for kids you know so uh yeah oh yeah that
our R rating man blazing trick yeah seriously
blazing a trail it earned that R and God that
little whole Ninja bit at the beginning that
was cool with the sound too it kind of gets
hot as it yeah there's a lot of clever and
fun choices in these movies I'm excited to
check out part three even if we may be past
the agreeable quality of the Blade trilogy
yeah I'm still interested but I'm still here
for it and maybe we'll love it who knows and
uh speaking of things that I'd be excited
to check out I want our Ip Man reviews to
do well so we can please check out the fourth
one we gotta finish it and then the fifth
one yeah yeah because they're gonna make it
I'm excited well you know keep on watching
those Donnie Yen videos keep on watching these
Blade videos you got any more stray thoughts
before we hit it no good job team Hells yeah
way to go could you if you all watching Leslie
I know you're watching Wesley Snipes big fan
of the channel good job team appreciate all
you guys for sticking with us if you need
a love interest for Wesley Snipes I know somebody
who would be very happy to sign up do you
yeah can you think of anybody somehow some
way I do know someone I can't imagine who
you could be speaking about but it's okay
live Live Your Dream Live Your Dream he is
I he's seeing him and Donnie in the same movie
was almost too much I know right I I don't
I do not uh yeah I I second that sentence
and I think in some ways they spared us because
if there was more Donnie we might not be sitting
here in such good shape I think we are right
now there's one scene where he's in the back
putting his shirt on he's not supposed to
be a focus of attention I can't tell you what
they were talking about in the scene because
I was like Donny's oh nervous perfectly placed
there and I was like point to the scene oh
Donnie [Laughter] will leave us new thoughts
people who did you think was the hottest person
in this movie and uh yeah let us know what
else you want to see and uh leave a like subscribe
all that good stuff last but not least still
a patron of the day
Everett pixel might Baker how you doing buddy
we were thinking of which Patron to shout
out today and I saw your bright red profile
pic and thought who would make the baddest
ass vampire Hunter at our patreon I bet that
could be you because you got might in your
name you're a strong character but also I
mean you gotta be able to slink through the
Shadows you got to be able to you know uh
you know the the the yeah think on your feet
unlike me that's why I wouldn't be as good
at your job as you would be because you would
be fast you would be sharp as a blade you
would be prepared yeah you would have all
the what would you I just think you're killing
it right now yeah you're welcome the two things
I think of when I think of Everett oh please
as a name and a thing number one ever it sounds
like Everest so you are a mountain my friends
and that's amazing number two I went to San
semi-formal with a guy named Everett sick
yeah it was dope dude well hey things maybe
you can guys can get together and go to another
semi-formal feeling of full form I think it's
illegal for me to go to a semi-formal anymore
all right a full form we go full form 100
formal you heard it here Everett just get
your Vamp gear meet Roxy for uh let's go ever
best ass formal of your young you can just
stop at Best ass sure I bet maybe it has an
amazing I bet Everett has an amazing average
ever it's got a mountain bird he's got bubble
butt yeah everybody out here doing squats
I feel like that's more of a hill a Mountain's
pointy yeah yes you don't want go on too many
Peaks on that ass as long as there's some
valleys to follow yes we love you thank you
for sticking around for whatever this is and
uh we'll see you next month and stay pledged
we love you and I hope you're doing well whatever
this is thank you